alex jones could soon face arrest
after calling out sick
for court-ordered depositions
in one of his sandy hook lawsuits the
day he said he couldn't show up he
hosted a four-hour infowars show alex
jones wants to defend himself uh he
wants to explain that he is is he better
now
infowars.com
infowars.com prisonplanet.tv all these
globalists like to go on and on about
the poor covet victims stay home you
need to quarantine meanwhile i get
legitimately sick 100 and it's jones's
fake and come out and sneeze all over us
jones well you can't have it both ways
you fill these sons of [ __ ] please
respect my privacy at this time i'm very
sick infowars.com
oh you sound healthier than ever
although i have to say you're surrounded
by all those products for healthy living
and why don't you just take those what's
going on here i'm gonna explain this
very gently to you we are living in a
bio weapon binary completion attack they
hit us with the spike protein delta was
real omicron was fake i am a victim you
are a victim you survive the attack we
will not aid and abet their murders
these people will pay in the name of
jesus they will pay for what they've
done
now face judgment
excuse me i'm loyal oh you're still
suffering are you alec
respect my privacy please
it says here the judge denied jones
request to delay the deposition due to
an undisclosed medical condition
says here the medical issues while
potentially serious are not currently
serious enough to either require his
hospitalization or convince him to stop
engaging in his broadcast
so your deposition is on that's all i'm
saying i you know i don't know anything
i can hear you're sick i hear that what
is that you have some sort of uh
yeah
oh excuse me i don't know if i can go to
the deposition this way
i'm sneezing all over the place howard i
i hope the doctor i hope the judge is
listening i really do i really do all
right alex uh anything else you want to
tell us uh any products you want to
promote i'm the only one putting you on
as far as i know
well that's about all we got to help
spring saving
oh yes it is
it is time to spring into savings howard
let me ask you a question where is the
only safe place to get globalist poison
free vitamins at this moment in time do
you know where
no i don't tell me
infowars.com the spring savings you're
gonna get 50 off alpha male bio force
the brain shield x9 vitamin j gummies we
have the x3 styrene packing peanut
chewables very good for you sold out for
eight months you can get half off
clinton's killed saggett t-shirts you're
gonna get great deals on liberty food
buckets high quality powdered food zero
mrna eat it right from the bucket use
the lid as a plate that's what i do
infowars.com spring saving infowars.com
all right well there you go
thank you very much
[Music]
you're sick your judge will see you
dancing and you'll be in big trouble use
your head all right